So, which is it? Do I not have a
lactase protein or do I have one that's non-functional?
>> Well, although it's possible to have a non-functional lactase protein,
we're pretty sure you did because, as a baby, you were able
to drink milk. So in your case, we would presume that
you have the lactase gene, but it's just not expressed any more.
>> Oh, once again Matt. What exactly do you mean by expressed?
>> What we mean by expressed is
whether or not a gene is transcribed and translated and turned
into protein. So a gene that's on, or expressed, means a gene
that's actually transcribed and translated into protein. And a gene that's
off or not expressed, is a gene that's not transcribed at all.
>> So, it's not that Shalu doesn't have the
lactase gene, it's just that it's not turned on.
>> Exactly, in this lesson, we're going to learn how
turning genes on and off is just as important
as making sure they have the right coding
sequence for a functional protein. We're going to focus particularly
on the non coding regions that can control
whether or not a gene starts transcription or not.
>> Now why don't you tell us? Are you
lactose intolerant like Shalu is? Check yes or no.